pour le moment les gestes sont amicaux
l'ambiance bon enfant à un an de la
ryder cup à saint quentin en yvelines
pour ce premier duel de capitaine sous
le soleil thomas bjorn et jim furyk
diriger des jeunes de l'équipe de france
une opposition amicale à quatre contre
quatre
mais surtout une expérience
enrichissante pour ces futurs
professionnels non valide notre
expérience puis ils sont vraiment là à
côté donc c'est génial quand la pression
connais pas trop ça enfin connaît pas
autant de pression
du coup c'est un grand coup j'avais
beaucoup de stress au début et
franchement ça va beaucoup dans ce
premier match entre américains et
européens les deux équipes ont terminé à
égalité
un résultat loin d'être une déception
surtout pour les enfants ils étaient
plus de 700 à pouvoir approcher les
stars du golf
on a essayé d'avoir des joueurs français
dans moi d'être ici et ont plaisir à la
rédac de l'année prochaine au fond dati
de voir déjà des gens qui iront bas la
grandeur déjà de tous les parcours c'est
mon c est surtout de voir des jeunes
espoirs l'événement a permis aussi aux
capitaines de prendre leurs marques sur
le parcours de l'albatros c'est ici que
les 24 joueurs des deux continents
s'opposeront pour la 42e édition de la
ryder cup c'est un parcours de golf
fantastique et d'être le capitaine de
cette ryder cup est vraiment spécial
c'est une journée incroyable avec tous
ses enfants je suis très excité à l'idée
de vivre cette ryder cup à paris
[Musique]
la ryder cup 2018 se tiendra du 25 au 30
septembre prochain près de deux cent
mille visiteurs sont attendus à saint
quentin en yvelines
la compétition reprendra alors tous ses
droits